what do a horror film a beloved sitcom
and a superhero movie all have in common
they all suffered from disastrous test
screenings from the bewildering to the
outright Unforgettable these screenings
ultimately killed the backbone of these
films and TV shows
2011's the thing prequel which followed
up John Carpenter's 80 sci-fi horror
classic is a notorious case of a film
being completely destroyed by the test
screening process if the number is high
there's a celebration if the number is
low when the preview cards stink well
let's just say many people will suffer
the film was written by Eric heiserer
who later earned an Oscar and bafta
nominations for his script for arrival
at this point in his career Heiser had
only written Final Destination 5 and the
2010 A Nightmare on Elm Street remake so
he was under pressure to incorporate all
of the major changes the studio imposed
in the aftermath of negative test
screenings for the thing after test
screenings and reshoots but before the
movie went into wide release Heiser ER
confessed that the poor response from
test audiences led the studio to bring
in the more experienced Scott Frank
writer of Minority Report and Get Shorty
for uncredited script doctoring in an
interview with Bloody Disgusting Heiser
ER said right now we get to the monster
as fast as possible since the test
screenings prove that's what those
audiences wanted I can't say yay or nay
to it but it does feel like there are
pieces of it missing the test screenings
also affected the film's special effects
the thing was originally shot with
practical effects just like Carpenter's
original film after test screenings the
studio opted to cover up the effects
with CGI
given that the NBC show Friends is one
of the most popular and successful
sitcoms ever made it likely comes as a
shock to learn it was extremely poorly
received in its early test screenings
NBC engages in extensive research and
testing for all of its new shows and the
test screenings of the Friends pilot
were so disastrous the show was nearly
axed instead of getting a full season
order traditionally after test audiences
view a pilot the aggregated result of
their reactions is boiled down to a
score between zero and a hundred a
series with successful prospects is
expected to score upwards of 70. friends
earned a measly 41 out of a hundred hey
you could do a lot worse than Joey
Tribbiani one of the biggest issues
mentioned by test audiences was that the
cast of Friends didn't seem like friends
they were put off by the lack of caring
warmth in Chemistry Between the main
characters who they considered to be
largely unlikable they didn't find the
show funny or compelling and indicated
that they wouldn't feel inclined to
watch subsequent episodes fortunately
NBC didn't listen and the series which
ran for 234 episodes went on to become
one of the highest rated series ever a
Batgirl movie starring Leslie Grace
Michael Keaton JK Simmons and Brendan
Fraser was supposed to be released in
2022 but it wound up getting permanently
shelved instead despite big names a 90
million dollar budget and plenty of hype
around its release Warner Brothers
discovery made the decision to pull the
plug and cancel its release altogether
the official line was that the
cancellation was part of a general
realignment of the company's plans for
the DC Universe and HBO Max this vague
explanation didn't ring true for most oh
you can trust me Badger I'd sooner trust
a snake with fangs at both ends it was
suggested that the real reason was a
combination of poor test screening
feedback and the financial benefit of
using the movie as a tax write-off the
town podcast hosts Matthew bellany
offered some insight in a Batgirl Focus
episode saying the studio was trying to
figure out whether it felt like it
deserved at theatrical release and the
consensus was absolutely not it played
like a TV pilot the stakes were very
small the poor test screenings coupled
with the underhanded tax benefit made
scrapping the film an appealing
alternative to a theatricor release
squandering all the time and energy
spent by everyone who worked on the
movie
a surreal sci-fi fantasy about the
Perils of dystopian bureaucracy 1985's
Brazil was directed by former Monty
Python member Terry Gilliam who had to
fight the studio tooth and nail to
preserve his directorial vision my
complication had a little complication
Universal president Sydney scheinberg
already had issues with gilliam's ideal
version of the film in poor test
screenings exacerbated the problem
gilliam's original cut of the film was
142 minutes long scheinberg and test
audiences agreed that was excessive
Universal wanted to cut the film to 94
minutes removing more than a third of
its total content test audiences didn't
like the dark ending either but
scheinberg didn't want Gilliam to shoot
a new ending preferring instead to Lop
off the ending sequence before The Bleak
reveal when Gilliam refused Universal's
response was to not release the film in
the U.S though it was available in the
UK via a different distributor with the
fate of his film in Jeopardy Gilliam
publicly called out universal he also
personally brought his cut in front of
La critics through private screening
they loved it and gave Brazil multiple
Awards putting pressure on universal to
release the film in the end Gilliam had
to make some edits but the Final Cut of
the film was 132 minutes significantly
longer than the 94 minute studio version
before Mulholland Drive became an
oscar-nominated and bafta winning film
it was intended to be a television show
filmmaker David Lynch had found major
success with Twin Peaks his first foray
into television the show became an
international phenomenon but it was
decidedly outside of the realm of
traditional TV and struggled in the
ratings in its second season before
being canceled several years later
Mulholland Drive was Lynch's attempt to
re-enter the world of Television he
wrote and directed the pilot episode
which was 90 minutes long just like his
earlier Twin Peaks pilot he brought the
pilot to ABC who had air Twin Peaks but
the network turned down the show after a
single test screening no other networks
were interested either though Lynch
nearly gave up on the project
broke I know but
Kelly he came into contact with Elaine
sard and Canal plus who gave him the
funding and the motivation to repurpose
the open-ended pilot into a
self-contained feature film the film
version of Mulholland Drive is now
considered a masterpiece but one can't
help but wonder what the series could
have been with all of the other
characters and side plots it might have
explored
the 2007 post-apocalyptic Thriller I Am
Legend was a massive box office success
bringing in well over half a billion
dollars worldwide despite the Undisputed
Financial win the film had some major
issues one of its biggest failings was
the direct result of poor test
screenings the original ending of 2007's
I Am Legend was more faithful to the
novel it was based on Dr Neville played
by Will Smith comes to learn that the
creatures he has been battling known as
dark Seekers are far more intelligent
and sophisticated than he's given them
credit for they have their own society
and aren't the malevolent mindless
monsters he thought in the end Neville
realizes he is the real monster in their
eyes as they see him abducting and
torturing them in his lap the meaning of
the title becomes clear in the closing
moments Neville is the legend the dark
Seekers fear after test audiences
reacted negatively to this ending the
studio panicked
I can save everybody a new ending was
designed to appease audiences but it
proved to be a miscalculation the film's
conclusion is unsatisfying undercuts the
movie's themes and contradicts the
entire point of the film and its source
material not to mention the title as
Neville no longer realizes he is the bad
guy Army of Darkness is the third film
in director Sam raimi's Evil Dead series
though you'd be forgiven for thinking it
was a standalone film based on the way
Universal marketed it raymie wanted to
call it medieval dead but the studio
didn't want to be associated with the
independently produced and extremely
gory first two movies in the series they
wouldn't allow any permutation of Evil
Dead in the title even though the second
film's final Cliffhanger is vital to
understanding the plot of Army of
Darkness since the first two Evil Dead
movies were made with such low budgets
raymie retained complete creative
control over them when Universal ponied
up a budget for Army of Darkness that
was dozens of times larger Remy's
creative control was significantly
lessened and test screenings became an
unavoidable part of the process after
the screenings the film changed
drastically the biggest alteration was
the ending raymie wanted to have Ash
played by Bruce Campbell attempt to
return from the past to the present but
make a bone-headed error that lands him
in an apocalyptic future where he goes
mad this was an on-brand ending that
suited the series but test audiences
considered it too Bleak you can make a
movie called Army of Darkness and the
audience goes that was a sad ending
we're like what this pushed Universal in
a different direction in The New Ending
ash makes it back to his present where
he has a fun and Goofy action scene in s
Mark to close out the film 28 Days Later
is a 2002 horror film set 28 days into a
zombie-like outbreak in London that has
decimated the population the film was
directed by Danny Boyle and written by
Alex Garland in his screenwriting debut
in Garland's original ending the main
character Jim played by Killian Murphy
died and left Selena played by Naomi
Harris and Hannah played by Megan and
burns to survive on their own test
audiences thought it too Bleak so a
replacement was whipped up in which Jim
survives and the three live a peaceful
life out in the countryside as the
future begins to look more hopeful this
new upending might sound fine in a
vacuum but it runs counter to the dark
realistic tone of the rest of the film
not to mention that it undercut some of
the film's major themes this was a story
that needed a bleak ending but test
audiences said no
Seinfeld towers as one of the most
beloved sitcoms of all time across its
nine Seasons the show racked up 10 Emmy
wins and an unbelievable 58 additional
nominations today the series ranks in
the top 50 highest rated TV shows of all
time and is fondly remembered but the
series almost failed to get off the
ground according to an article in TV
Guide audience research conducted by NBC
stated no segment of the audience was
eager to watch the show again nothing
for you
the show was called boring unfunny and
confusing even NBC executive Brandon
tartikoff thought the series was too New
York and Jewish Centric because of the
terrible reception the show premiered in
the middle of the summer usually a sign
that the network had no interest in
taking it any further that's why the
first season of Seinfeld consisted of
just five episodes whereas later Seasons
typically contain the standard 22
Episodes despite its chances for Success
being hamstrung by its own network the
quality of the series shine through and
the show managed to find its audience
with the deck stacked against it
Seinfeld proved its detractor is wrong
Little Shop of Horrors is the 1986 film
adaptation of the musical stage play of
the same name which was itself or
reimagining of Roger corman's ultra low
budget horror comedy from 1960 but the
studio Warner Brothers was initially
unwilling to put out a film that
receives such a negative reaction with
test audiences the big issue was the
ending which had worked so well on the
stage director Frank Oz told
Entertainment Weekly that the test
screening was going wonderfully at first
saying there was Applause they loved it
it was just fantastic however the
audience reaction soured instantly at
the end of the film The Original ending
had Seymour played by Rick Moranis get
eaten and killed by the talking plant
Audrey too she then grows to gigantic
Heights Rampages through New York City
and climbs to the top of the Statue of
Liberty before busting through the
screen winning in the end while the
heroes perish test audiences hated the
ending Oz explained you have to have a
55 percent recommend to really be
released and we got a 13. Warner
Brothers Force oz to shoot a new happier
ending that let the heroes live under
the threat of having the film go
unreleased Oz begrudgingly complied
looking back he said we had to do it and
do it in such a manner that the audience
would enjoy the movie it was very
dissatisfying
[Music]